and lastly on the facebook for kids for
cash you see just the outpour of
comments from people within the
community how's that been for you i mean
people are they just feel seems like
that the story is finally out in the
open it's finally being told but it
seems like there's more that they still
want to talk about i think the
interesting thing about facebook is that
you know when a movie like this first
comes to be you know you get a facebook
like or two but this had more facebook
likes than most any other in fact i
think than any other independent film of
late before the movie ever opened and
and the anticipation for it's been
overwhelming for us you know and i think
that's important though it's like when
people
like like our facebook page when they
like it it just shows support of what
the film's about and i think that the
kids feel that too because they're on
there they're watching those those
facebook likes and such they are and and
it and it's good
the kids feel finally they have a voice
and and i think they know they're
speaking for a lot of other kids and
families around the country which is a
really good feeling for them and for me
too